it burns my pathos and welcome to your
force market analysis for Thursday
September 21st 2017 it's been a while
since I've done one of these I've had
kind of a busy week but I'm got
something interesting to show you oh
it's one of the benefits of using an
order for so the market it's kind of
quiet today
you know that the Fed I believe is
starting their unwinding already and you
know Dow is up less I was down uh-huh
keep so used to saying it's up it was
down marginally I think comes like 0.2%
but first a brief disclaimer this
presentation is for educational and
informational purposes only and should
not be considered a solicitation to buy
or sell a futures contract or make any
other type of investment decision
futures trading contains substantial
risk and is not for every investor
investor could potentially lose all on
more than the initial investment risk
capital is money that could be lost not
jeopardizing one's financial security or
lifestyle risk capital should be used
for training and only those with
sufficient risk capital should consider
trading past performance is not
necessarily indicative of future results
those used in this presentation are the
order flow straighter volume footprint
chart the Delta scalper and the Delta s
re end the price rejector so what I'm
going to show you is this is really one
of the benefits of using order flow and
if you're not using an order flow you're
really missing out on a lot of juicy
information so let me just pull up okay
so here it is in the euro currency it's
late in the session it was around the
two o'clock time Chicago time 2:00 p.m.
but you can see this volume here
1026 that's massive for the euro
currency its massive for any currency
but it's it's very I don't what's the
term to say you know this is why people
like to use order flows because they
could see this information if you're
just using a normal bar chart okay
you're not gonna see and you're not
gonna see that the type of volume dish
traded there this is market generated
volume like it's market generated
information you can see that there was a
huge bid there 1026 right and what
happens after this the market goes up
right even into the evening session even
traits higher above 120 even so you know
that you have very strong buying
supportive buying you know people
basically stepping up at this price
level and saying you know I
I'm a bitter here you know I'll just buy
everything and you can see how the
market reacts you know and if you're not
using or derful if you're just looking
at a normal bar chart you're not gonna
see that information you know I'll show
you what it looks like on a normal bar
chart all right so this is the normal
bar chart this is the bar right here
this one you can see that this bar right
here this is the bar with a big bottom
if you're looking at a chart you know
that arranged card if you're just
looking at a normal chart you can't tell
it you know that this market is going to
rally up off this you know that there's
a strong support of mine you can't you
just not seen that information you know
I know it candlestick guys Forex guys
well you got a pin bar here we had one
here you had one here this market didn't
do anything off this you know though
this market went sideways but here this
is where this bar is where you see that
volume now you know the other thing is I
don't know if it's even worth noting but
you know it that price is 1 1985 right
just sort of scroll back 1 1985 4 are
you here you know yeah it did come back
right to this point or the year I mean
sorry at 10:30 you know that we did
rally up break out through the new highs
came back down to 85 and then shot up
but if you look at the volume I mean it
wasn't nothing nothing spectacular it
was just average
you know 61 you had unfinished business
you know I know unfinished business
people who can't say yeah you're an
unfinished business we came back to it
much later in the day but yeah it's
that's a bit of a stretch the unfinished
business here we haven't come back to it
yet but anyway this is I mean if there's
only one reason for using order flow and
this just to see the volume you know
once things really stand out like that
then you know you should be using order
flow and your trading so it doesn't take
much else to just put it over a normal
chart you could put it over a normal
candlestick chart like you see here it
just makes it makes life a lot easier
you know sometimes you get stuff like
this every day no you don't honestly but
you know when you get it you know it's
it's it's just awesome you know I don't
know any other way to say it
it's just a great feeling to see stuff
like that and see how the market reacts
and you know and write it you know that
that's what you want to do as the
traders you want to catch things like
the pieces of information like that are
that nobody else is really paying
attention to okay so you know just what
else really quick look at the British
Pound I'll just show you a quick chart
of the British Pound it's a it's just a
bar chart but it just makes it easier to
see this is the Delta scalper indicator
so this morning you know you had a
signal here didn't work out but then
looks after you know 738 you get a nice
buy signal here around the 135 40 area
and what does it do just goes straight
up the entire day you get a sell up here
136 above the 136 even area so you know
what if you catch a move like that you
know and then it's happy days right
that's what you want as a traders you
want to catch those big moves yeah you
got a loss here I mean that's fine it's
not the end of the world you know you
could you take that and you move on you
look for the next trade and the next
trade comes and it's it's a big winner
you know you're risking you know know
that is nine ticks but you getting back
60 ticks you know that's the risk reward
that you want to be getting this is the
e-mini zation want to show you this is
the Delta scalper so this morning you
know we're really going sideways
chop-chop-chop here you got your last
sell signal before the big sell-off you
got a little sell here that works out
little by here the sell not so much but
then even in the evening session you get
some signals right before the big
sell-off I think there was another some
news coming out of Korea but you know
it's we're starting to come off this
market you know there's interesting Jim
James Rogers again was on some interview
and predicting the greatest bear market
of all time of history I don't know why
these people get him on you know he's
been predicting saying this for the last
15 years it seems I mean I remember even
when I was living in Singapore and see
him on the news all this is the biggest
there is very market ever then he talks
about you know how great China is you
know I think China is a bigger bubble
right now than the US but that's just
that's my own analysis I don't want
people coming up to me said well you
should join it was going to so often it
didn't just really quick I'll just show
you this this is the bonds anything
interesting here this this bar also very
interesting I mean again you know this
is one of the perks of using order flow
you could see this heavy volume up here
17:13 because you've got 1473 on traded
on the offer
17:13 on the bid so you know this market
excuse me you know so it's nine bit at
ten okay
tens aren't trading and everyone is
telling the heck out of nines goes nine
offered and it sells off this type of
bar is extremely bearish i mean very
rarely do you get that sort of volume on
the bid side of a down candle you just
don't you know and then again you know
it's the unfinished business and people
say oh it came back to it yeah i came
back to it in the next session but at
that point that's really you getting
some other bullish signs you got a price
rejecter down here you got the delta
scalper here and just sort of go
sideways to the closer then rallies in
the evening session i mean you know you
could i'd rather be you know taking the
buy here then saying we got unfinished
business expect the market to come back
there at some point in the history in
the future you know there's a bit of a
stretch and rather be having signals
like here you got the bullish ratio you
got price reject your single print you
know delta scalper in the next bar you
know so all signs are going that this
markets going to go up and it does
eventually in the next session but you
know i think that's a better assessment
of what to expect for the market than
just saying it unfinished business here
but this bar anyway this bar very
bearish bar very bearish bar when you
get this sort of volume up on top of
that bar and the market sells off okay
so thanks for watching this video and
you know be sure to subscribe to the
youtube channel you could learn a lot
more about trading with order flow just
you know go to my websites and you know
sign up for the free delta scalper
indicator
yeah I've been saving these questions I
got lot of questions coming up from
people about order flow and I'm gonna
try and create a video about it tonight
or you know over the weekend but one of
the questions was you know the Delta
scalper in Decatur okay order flow
indicators they run on the data as it
comes in right like I showed you that
British Pound chart and we just get back
to it that's the Delta scalper but the
the Delta surge is the same way people
say you know I loaded a chart and it's
not appearing well the reason why it's
not appearing is because the way the
data is handled right if I were to load
a British Pound chart right now these
deltas are gap ler this is the Delta
scalper these Delta scalper signals
would not appear because it reads the
data as it comes in it doesn't read
historical data okay so don't think you
could just load a chart a blank chart
and then load the indicator and it's
gonna appear it's not okay it's not
gonna appear it's gonna read the data as
it comes in you know that would be like
saying I have a dome and I want to load
historical data on it well no you got to
run it in replay right because it's
reading the data as it comes in right
and it doesn't read historical past data
period unless you're on NT 8 which
handles data completely different NT 7
and NT 8 the way they handle the data is
two different ways okay and you could
save the data so when you reload a chart
in NinjaTrader 8 it'll have the data now
you know the one thing I've noticed
about that I don't know if it's just me
but when you enable the data to be saved
on NT 8 it really takes up a lot of disk
space so make sure you got a you know
computer with a lot of hard drive space
and I think over time you'll probably
want to transfer those files I mean
those contracts expire right these are
futures contracts so you know after you
know right now we're trading December
British pounds so after the December
contract expires you probably want to
move those than data off your off your
PC onto a onto an external drive or
something but the only really it'll take
up space I found it it takes up space
now granted I run a lot of charts so you
know one day's worth of data is like one
gig
but I've literally got a boatload of
charts running so just keep that in mind
with NinjaTrader eight again I don't
know if it's just me and the way my PC
was configured but I did notice that it
was using up a lot of memory in that
respect so anyway thanks for watching
this go to order Flo's calm or go to
Delta scalper calm and be sure to
subscribe to the YouTube channel thanks
and have a great day bye bye